Let's start with,
um,
what should we be doing with kids to
make them tougher so that, you know,
as they live in the world is a
safer and safer cars are safer.
The death rate for kids is,
has been plummeting for all,
all causes other than suicide,
which has gone up. Um,
so as kids live in a safer and safer
world, they also have the internet,
which is going to expose them to
virtual insults for ever and ever.
So how are we going to raise kids to
be maximally effective in this new 21st
century world, which is physically
very safe but virtually unsafe. Okay.
How are we gonna do that?
Um,
and I think the key idea that we need to
put on the table here and that I think
everybody who works with kids needs to
keep in mind every day is antifragility.
I know you've talked about that on this
show before, but I'll just, I should,
I can just give a very brief explanation
of it cause it's such an important
concept. Um, so, uh,
antifragility a lot of listeners will
know is a word coined by Naseem to lab.
The Guy who wrote the Black Swan,
um,
because there are certain
systems and he was,
I think he was motivated by the
collapse of the banking system.
So he had predicted the collapse because
he said the banking system is really
convoluted and it's never been tested.
A system needs to be tested, challenged,
shocked in order to then
develop defenses against it.
And our system has not been tested. So if
anything goes wrong, it's all gone down.
All right. You reference him quite
a few tick. Yes, that's right.
He's really concept of venture. Fragile.
That's right. It's a key idea in,
in our book and it, I find as I
talk about this around the country,
once you explain this to
people who work with kids,
like everybody gets it
right away. All right? So,
so [inaudible] says there's no
word for this property. He says,
we, we, we know that
some things are fragile.
And so like if you have a glass lean
of have a wine glass on the table,
you knock it over, it breaks. Okay. It
doesn't get better in any way. And so, uh,
you know,
you don't give kids a wineglass.
You give them a plastic sippy
cup because plastic is resilient.
But if a kid knocks over a sippy cup,
it doesn't get better in any way.
And to let wanted to know what's the word
for things that do get better when you
knock them over. And the classic
example is the immune system.
So the immune system is
an incomplete system.
It's a miracle of evolution that we
have this system for making, you know,
antibodies. Um, but it doesn't know
exactly what to be reactive to.
That has to be set by
childhood experience.
And so if you keep your kids in a bubble
and you use bacterial wipes and you
don't let them be exposed to bacteria,
you're crippling the system.
The system has to get knocked over.
It has to get challenged, threatened.
It has to have a, it has to learn
how to it, uh, expand its abilities.
And so, um, so this is why peanut
allergies are going up. Yeah.
Those are really shocking part
of your book. That's right.
It's stunning how fast this happened.
Please explain that to people.
The whole peanut allergy thing.
Yeah.
So peanut allergies used to be really
rare and most of us, you know, older folk,
we brought peanut butter
sandwiches to school. Uh,
and when my son Max started
preschool in, uh, 2008, you know,
they went on and on about no nuts,
nothing that touched and not
nothing that looks like a nut,
nothing that has the word Nadia.
I mean,
it was crazy how defensive they were
about nuts. And as we write in the book,
I thought back on that and I said,
wait a second, like, why? You know,
we're freaking out about nuts.
And the more we freak out about it,
the higher the allergy rate goes.
And it turns out there was a study
done and published in 2015 where the
researchers noticed that the allergy to
nuts is only going up in countries that
tell pregnant women to avoid nuts. And
they thought, well, maybe that's why.
And so they did a controlled experiment.
They got about 600 women who had given
birth recently and ha and whose kids were
at higher risk of analogy cause they
had Eczema or some other, you know,
immune system sort of issue.
So about 300 of them are told
standard advice, your kids at risk,
the peanut allergy,
so you should not eat peanuts while
you're lactating and keep peanuts,
weaken your kid. And the other half
were told here is an Israeli snack food.
It's a popcorn with a peanut,
a peanut powder dusting on the outside,
give it to your kids,
starting at, you know,
three or four months whenever
they're ready to eat. And
so, and they monitor them,
they made sure that they weren't,
you know,
fatal reactions or sewer or
strong reactions. And then,
uh, at the age of five,
they gave them all a very
thorough immunological tests.
And of the ones who followed the standard
advice, 17% had a peanut allergy.
They would have to watch out for
peanuts for the rest of their lives.
Just such a high number
because these were,
because these were kids who
are already predisposed. Um,
and but the half that were
predisposed but given peanut powder,
3%, just 3% had a peanut allergy
at age five. In other words,
we could almost wipe out peanut allergies
by giving peanut powder to kids.
And it just a few months ago in science,
the front page article was on doing that.
And so again,
good intentions and bad ideas.
We're trying to protect our kids soap.
Oh keep them away from peanuts.
But that's exactly the wrong advice
because kids are antifragile and so we're
doing the same thing.
Most of them,
the real issue was the people that don't
have an actual severe allergy of what's
your child. Yeah. Yes.
But that's what this science article was
about was that a exposure therapies are
being tested and they are
the most effective. So
you just have to start slow. So you
give him a very small, exactly. Yeah.
Cause I was on a plane once and they
informed us that they didn't want us to
even eat peanuts on the plane because
there was someone on the plane that was so
allergic, right. That if you eat peanuts
and you chew it and it's in the air,
it could adversely affect that person.
Yeah. And that could well be true.
So I have no objection to that.
But the reason we got to that point is
because we started banning peanuts long
ago. So this is one of these I bought, I'm
not sure if it's a problem at progress,
but as we know it's not
necessarily, but, um,
but it's an example of
antifragility. Right. Okay.
So now let's bring this to the playground.
All right. So, um, you know, when,
when you and I were kids,
you know,
boys and girls have different social
interactions, but boys tease each other,
right? And salt each other. You
throw around insults, right? Yeah.
And that's part of developing to be a boy.
Now if it turns into bullying like
a bunch of kids or why, you know,
is our after one kid day after
day. Okay. That's terrible.
We have to do something about that.
I'm not saying bullying is okay,
but as we've cracked down on bullying
and as we've gotten more and more
sensitive about harm in general, we're
cracking down on any kind of teasing,
cruelty exclusion. So my kids go to
New York City public schools, uh,
which are generally pretty good.
Um, but on the playground, you know,
there's a monitor and the
playground monitor low. You
know, if there's conflict,
he comes and checks it out. If a kid is
crying, he checks it out. Um, you know,
seems like a good thing to do,
but it's like treating kids like
they're allergic to peanuts.
Kids have to have thousands
and thousands of conflicts.
They have to be exposed to
insults and exclusion and teasing.
And if you can imagine,
if you could keep your daughter in a
protective tank where nobody would tease
her or insult or hurt her feelings for 18
years, would you do it? Absolutely not.
It's not important. It's important
that they do experience some assholes.
They just have to know.
But the, on the flip side,
there are certain people that are
damaged for the rest of their life,
by bullies and some like I have a friend,
um,
and his brother used to beat him up when,
when they live together and it's
still fucks with him to this day.
And he's in his 50s. Yeah. Like I, he,
I think he has a certain
level of depression that's
directly correlated. Yeah.
I mean, I can't say about your
friend, but the research shows,
the research does show that um,
bullying can leave permanent scars.
So there are a couple things
we have to keep our eye on.
Kids are antifragile yes,
but, but, um, two things.
One is they need challenges that are
graded to their level of ability.
So if they're overwhelmed and if
the suffering goes on day after day.
So if kids are bay,
if their brain is bathed in cortisol.
So cortisol is a normal stress hormone.
You have to experience stress,
you have to have cortisol. And then it
drops goes up and down, up and down.
But kids who are raised
either in an invite where
they're bullied or their abuse
at home, they don't have a
secure attachment relationship,
then they get brain damage, then you,
you're hurting kids if it's chronic.
So I'm in no way saying bullying as,
okay. I, you've got to keep them.
You've got to keep the line.
But, but again, you have to
look at each institution.
So each school is not thinking,
hmm,
how can we carefully draw the line
between bullying and valuable sorts of
conflict? No. They're thinking, well,
if we do this well, we get sued.
And if we're not really careful
at bullying, we're gonna get sued.
And so let's overreact. Let's go this
way. Yeah. Yeah. That's unfortunate.
Really. Um, but how do you decide
how much bullying is accept,
like venom, but giving them a little
bit so they develop a tolerance. Yeah.
Well, so there's, um, we, so we
did some research on bullying.
We didn't put it in the book because
while we suspect that anti bullying
policies that,
that go too far and that band conflict,
while we suspect that those are harmful,
we couldn't prove that.
So we didn't put this in the book,
but the,
the traditional definitions of bullying
are actually pretty reasonable. Uh,
I hope I can remember exactly.
It's like there's a, uh,
there's like a power
differential and it's a chronic,
you know, it goes on for
multiple, multiple days. Um,
and originally there was actually
a threat of violence, um,
had to be at least a threat of violence.
I think that was the original definition.
Uh,
and then that was expanded
gradually. Um, um,
so that doesn't have to be necessarily
thread of violence, but it,
it has expanded so far that like,
my kids use the term.
If one kid is mean to another, they'll
call that bullying. And that's too far.
So I think you have to keep your
eye on the key features too far.
If a kid is mean, yeah, but
you can't call it. So, um, so,
uh, like on the, on the
playground for my daughter,
the girls would form these clubs. And so
my daughter was in the Kitty cat club,
that that's what three girls called
themselves and they'd be in a corner and
they'd say, Oh, you can't,
you know, you can't join us.
You're not in the Kitty cat club.
Um, that's mean that's exclusion,
right? We can't have that. Right. So the,
so you don't have to like allow everyone
in your group because you don't want to
be a bully. That's, yeah. I don't
know. They called that bullying,
but her teacher had a conversation
with them. Now she didn't,
I don't think she exactly ordered them.
Never exclude.
So it'd be okay if you use it as a
grounds for discussion, but increased.
But some schools have even tried to
discourage the existence of best friends
because if you have best friends, you're
excluding others. That's hilarious.
It is hilarious. But again, it's,
if you fail to understand that kids
are antifragile and you think, oh my,
you know,
there's a rise of anxiety and depression
and girls are cutting themselves at
such high rates. You know, we've got it.
We've got to relieve them of stress. Like,
no, that's, that's not the
right way to go about it.